we are now starting to hear from some
MPs leaving the room about what the
prime minister said and a quote that has
been confirmed to be from a minister is
that the Prime Minister said that she
was prepared to leave this job earlier
than I intended in order to secure a
smooth and orderly brexit another MP who
emerged from the room said that she made
it clear that she wants someone in that
room someone a Conservative MP to be the
next prime minister and that she was
conscious that while she intended to put
the country first she also needed to put
the interest of the party in her mind
and when that seemed to factor into what
she was telling them in committee room
14 she didn't set a date but the clear
sense according to one MP was that it
would be and this is the quote they gave
me reasonably soon that's not the Prime
Minister that one of the MPs who emerged
from the room and they said that the
impression was that would be before the
next phase of talks now apparently she
also gave a short centre statement about
how the fact she acknowledged that she
has made some mistakes that she is not
someone who has spent time in the tea
rooms or the bars of the House of
Commons that perhaps she has not been
collegiate in some respects you know
this is something that she's being
criticized often many times for was in a
Kay about this actually not particularly
club herbal MP but she says she does
recognize that but that she has always
put the interests of the country and the
party at the front of her thinking so
that is the latest we are getting but as
I should say that the Prime Minister is
still in the room there are still
questions being put to her there was a
very long sustained period of banging of
desks and the doors at one point I
assume that is the moment that she set
out what she was planning to do but we
don't know for certain obviously because
we are not in the room
however she the Prime Minister is still
there she's still taking questions and
we'll bring you more as we get it